يصوت اعضاء اكاديميه الاوسكار في سبع عشره
فئه مختلفه لكن الفيلم يجب ان يستوفي
العديد من المعايير ليتم اعتباره جديدا
بالترشح لجائزه الاوسكار اولا يجب ان يكون
الفيلم اطول من اربعين دقيقه وان يتم
اصداره خلال العام الذي يسبق الحفل ويعرض
في دار عرض تجاريه في لوس انجلوس لمده
اسبوع على الاقل اذا استوفى الفيلم هذه
المعايير يمكن وقتها تقديمه وفي حال قبوله
يرسل الى الاعضاء الذين يحق لهم التصويت
في الاكاديميه كتب الاصوات بعد ذلك الى
شركه الاستشارات في دبليو سي التي تحصل
الارقام وتصدر قائمه باعلى 5 مرشحين لكل
فئه من حيث الاصوات ثم يصوت الاعضاء مره
اخيره قبل ان توضع النتائج في اظرف مغلقه
حتى ليله الحفل اعتبارا من عشرين عشرين
منحت الاكاديميه حق التصويت لبضعه الاف
اخرين لتشمل مختلف الاعمار والاعراق وتتيح
الفرصه لمزيد من النساء كانت تلك محاوله
لردع الانتقادات القائله ان معظم الاعضاء
مسنون وبيض